we cannot be too cautious right now and
that especially rings true for folks
like Sharon and Ozzy Osbourne they're at
high risk because she is a cancer
survivor and he is battling Parkinson's
I heard Ozzy is doing a lot better he is
and we're like oh my god the way our
Luck's go and we're all gonna get it so
it's like we're not chancing anything we
don't go out anywhere Sharon and Ozzy
were supposed to leave tomorrow to see a
doctor in Switzerland who specializes in
treating Parkinson's the 71 year old
rocker was on the wait list for months
and now he has to reschedule we hope
that you know please God everybody is
well and the world is back to normal
again and people can travel what are you
guys doing while you're in the house
well we've been doing things like jigsaw
puzzles and you know the usual thing
that you do all I'm gonna clean out the
closet so I'm gonna you know do the
pantry do this do that and then after
the first week you're like nah I'm bored
of that now mm-hmm how's Kelly doing I
feel bad for her because you know we
hear so she's on her own I want Kelly to
come here I did have a cry yesterday
because I miss my parents so the last
time I saw them was three and a half
weeks ago later on I'm gonna go over and
we're gonna have a cup of tea I'm gonna
be outside he's gonna be inside she saw
you guys just through the glass for the
first time in three and a half weeks she
came and we actually sat at big
distances around the pool I'm just like
all teary I just went out of use sure
has been busy taping new episodes of the
talk all the ladies are shooting from
home you know everybody's got their
pajama bottoms on I'm thinking maybe
we'll keep it like this forever why go
back to the studio how's the rest of our
voice you're shooting right now what are
you using to zoom with that I'm in right
now is a dumpy room in the house need
any wires I've got some wiring this is
as good as it gets
[Music]